at the white house the job of
interpreting every word falls to a
groundbreaking team of american sign
language interpreters ed o'keefe takes
us inside their work
good afternoon at the white house the
president first lady and the press
secretary are usually the most familiar
faces but for thousands of americans
that box in the right hand corner of the
white house live stream is where their
eyes usually focus
elsie snecker is the first official
white house american sign language
interpreter this is a dream job of that
combination of the political information
and the interpreting it fits me very
very well every day whenever the
president speaks my fellow americans
whenever gensake holds a press briefing
i know there are a few topics to discuss
or when experts like dr anthony foucher
share new information from the white
house the safety of these vaccines have
been clearly established elsie is on
screen too i have to recognize and thank
really the deaf community and the
grassroots deaf people who pushed so
hard to make sure that this access was
available about half a million use
american sign language which is not the
english version of sign language but its
own language entirely with its own
grammar and sentence structure during
the pandemic advocates sued to get live
asl interpretation during covet
briefings we will have an asl and
american sign language interpreter for
the biden administration went a step
further hiring elsie who's deaf as a
member of the staff we spoke to her with
the assistance of miaco villanueva who
signed my questions to her and spoke her
answers back absolutely i am blessed to
be here and elsie is just one half of a
team this is really the ultimate of
team relationships lindsey snyder who
can hear is also an asl interpreter i am
interpreting from english to asl and i
am
essentially feeding elsie who then
takes that message and interprets it
what i call it real time editing elsie
and lindsey spent hours each day
preparing by reading up on the news and
topics on the white house schedule when
an event starts thank you thank you very
very much lindsay listens
then interprets for elsie we're seeing
the beginnings of an american
manufacturing comeback who signs in
front of the camera is the united states
is in a position to out-compete the
world once again onto your screen
there's no limit to what we can achieve
none
they could just hire someone like
lindsay to do this work but in essence
they've gone the extra step of hiring
somebody who is completely deaf deaf
people who are asl users can watch and
identify that it's a deaf person signing
on the screen most hearing interpreters
they learned asl so they have an accent
in asl where a deaf person who grew up
using asl doesn't have that same kind of
accent we also as deaf interpreters can
gauge what a deaf audience would
potentially need that some kind of
terminology is clearer than others some
things need a little bit more expansion
and explanation natural performers with
a great sense of timing they say the
best part of their day
is the daily press briefing one of my
favorite parts and it's actually related
to you are you ready okay
often someone will ask a question and
then on infrastructure and she answers
it back on infrastructure and then
somebody else asked a question and i'm
like in the back of my mind didn't they
already ask that and then the third
person asked and i'm like she answered
it already so i'm having this argument
with myself in the back of my head while
i'm working and trying to keep my cool
on the screen is there something those
of us in the room should be doing to
help it along
make friends with your consonants i love
i love a good articulator the one year
anniversary of the american rescue plan
i also believe that no one speaks or
reads faster than jensaki
believe it or not elsie and lindsey had
never met saki in person it's so nice to
meet you but we helped arrange a meeting
yeah rats briefings are my favorite we
tell everyone i heard maybe i talk a
little fast okay i'll work on that too
this is the ultimate kind of team we
have our own skill set that manages to
come together to put out the most
effective message
to bring in a community that's been
marginalized for so long i'm not here
for myself to be in this position i'm
here for the deaf community to have
access to this message for cbs mornings
i'm ed o'keefe at the white house
ed o'keefe that was so interesting i
never thought about a difference tony
a hearing interpreter and an interpreter
who's deaf that they would translate
differently such a charming interesting
piece uh yeah no the idea that if you
are born deaf you have a different way
of signing than a person who is learning
it as a hearing uh adult that's very
interesting like there's an accent to
the movements yeah i'll be curious to
see if jin saki slows down they said she
talks too fast well you've got to be
yourself